ich rufe auf den einzelplan 09
bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf drucksachen 16
9 und 16 26 und ich baue darauf dass sie
ganz zügig ihre plätze wechseln
und vielleicht auch etwas geräuschloser
da sind wir mal gespannt ob das jetzt
funktioniert ja zu diesem etat der jetzt
aufgerufen wird der rund elf milliarden
euro umfasst muss man ja tatsächlich gar
nicht viel sagen werden das ist eines
der zentralen thema themen in den
vergangenen monaten dass die in dieses
ressort fallen von bundeswirtschafts-
und klimaschutzminister habeck der auch
schon eine ganze weile hier im plenum
angekommen ist und auch bei der vorigen
debatte schon zugehört hat gasspeicher
beispielsweise die 200 milliarden euro
für den klimaschutz
die konzertierte aktion die der
bundeskanzler gestern morgen ins
gespräch gebracht hat der ausbau von
windenergie dann ist er endlich die
spritpreise zu kontrollieren so hat es
jedenfalls
die fdp formuliert in diesen tagen und
ja all das beschäftigt uns schon geraume
zeit wird es auch gleich seinen
widerhall finden in dieser debatte in
der der erste redner sein wird andreas
mattfeldt aus der unionsfraktion
das ganze wird 90 minuten dauern von
jetzt an und jetzt wird auch der erste
redner aufgerufen einsteigen
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren bevor ich in die feinheiten
des haushaltes einsteige dann möchte ich
mich bei ihnen herr minister habeck ich
möchte mich bei ihrem haus
stellvertretend bei ihrer
staatssekretärin anja hajduk und
natürlich beim gesamten haushalts
referaten stephanie will hat an der
spitze für eine außergewöhnlich gute
zusammenarbeit bedanken
mein dank gilt aber auch einen mit
berichterstattern für den fairen und im
menschlichen umgang über alle
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg allerdings
und hier kommen hin zur debatte über den
haushalt 20 22 hätte ich mir seitens der
ampel koalition schon gewünscht dass ihr
euch die anträge von uns als union ein
wenig genauer einfach mal angeschaut
hätte anstelle dieser einfach weil hier
her sagt falscher absender einfach immer
nur weg zum bügeln ich glaube es wäre
klug und das war auch eigentlich sonst
immer üblich bei der einen oder anderen
sache hier gemeinsam zu agieren das
haben sie nicht getan
mit
13,1 2 milliarden
mitteln im einzelplan 09 unter habe mit
noch mehr mitteln im energie und
klimafonds hätte man glaube ich mehr als
genug möglichkeiten gehabt zuge und auch
sinnvolle ansätze aus reihen der
opposition zumindest anzudenken
gegebenenfalls sogar
umzusetzen überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen konnte ich herr habeck
warum sie unseren antrag zur erneuten
teilnahme des wirtschaftsministeriums an
der jugendmesse ideenexpo in hannover
schlichtweg abgelehnt haben mehrfach
habe ich auch sie persönlich hierauf
angesprochen meine empörung während der
ausschusssitzung ich glaube die es ihnen
auch nicht verborgen geblieben auf der
ideenexpo meine damen und herren wir
haben junge leute
die chance sich über technische berufe
zu informieren und was das wichtigste
ist sie können mit ganz zahlreichen
unternehmen persönlich in kontakt treten
ich glaube nur so begegnen wir den
fachkräftemangel gerade in diesen so
wichtigen mangelberufen es müssen doch
nicht noch mehr menschen
politikwissenschaften studieren da haben
wir hier im saal was gott ja auch schon
mehr als genügend vor und wenn ich das
sagen darf ihre vorgänger peter altmaier
brigitte zypries die haben es sich nicht
nehmen lassen genau wie 400.000 junge
menschen auf der ideenexpo diesen einen
besuch abzustatten sie waren sogar
richtig stolz auf den stand ihres
ministeriums und unter ihrer führung er
habe hat sich dieser stand jetzt
erledigt aber vielleicht wenn sie in
sich gehen denken sie hierüber ja noch
einmal nach und meine damen und herren
mehr zielorientiertes handeln der ampel
das hätten wir uns auch im bereich der
beruflichen bildung erhofft bei der
ausstattung der fortbildungseinrichtung
und der überbetrieblichen
lehrlingsausbildung
abgelehnten maßgabe beschluss formuliert
dass wir diese titel dauerhaft und ich
betone dauerhaft und nicht nur einmalig
gut ausstatten müssen nur so
signalisieren wir doch eine
wertschöpfung für ausbildungsberufe und
das gerade im handwerk und mehr hofft er
habe das hätte ich auch beim zentralen
innovationsprogramm mittelstand und
industrie forschung egf diese für die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres landes so
erfolgreichen und wichtigen programme
die hätten wir beim zb um 100 millionen
euro anheben müssen um einen peinlichen
neuen antragsstopp das zu vermeiden und
ähnliches gilt bei ihnen hier auch für
die industrielle gemeinschaftsforschung
und er habe lasse mich noch ein paar
worte zu dem energie und klimafonds
sagen den sie ja zu 85%
bewirtschaften hier stehen in den
kommenden jahren milliarden beträge in
dreistelliger
zur verfügung und leider habe ich bei
den neuen titeln die sie eingebracht
haben bislang sehr sehr wenig konkretes
gesehen und erwarte ich dass sie bis ins
letzte detail jedes projekt und
spezifizieren aber ein wenig mehr als
nur haushaltstitel mitsummen oder gar
das muss man sich auf der zunge zergehen
lassen zahlreiche leer titel
einzubringen mit verlaub da hätte man
viel viel mehr erwarten dürfen nicht
einmal konkrete fragen was man denn in
etwa vor hat und wie die kosten
aufgeteilt werden konnten beantwortet
werden der minister das geht so nicht
hier sind sie noch antworten schuldig
ich hoffe diese werden in den kommenden
wochen monaten noch kommen und
unverständlich was hat da warum sie
unser konkreten antrag die mittel für
klimaneutrales fliegen um 350 millionen
anzuheben genauso abgesehen haben wie
die förderung zur produktion von
biokraftstoffen oder eben neue
antriebstechnologien in der luft hat
hier haben sie den titel schon um 700
millionen euro gesenkt auch das ist
nicht nachvollziehbar und ich frage mich
ernsthaft wie dies in ihren öffentlichen
ankündigungen zur klimaneutralität passt
und die größte herausforderung her habe
ich das ist die rohstoffsicherung für
unsere nation
mehrfach glaube ich haben wir beiden
hierüber gesprochen ich habe ihnen
geraten unsere bundesanstalt für
rohstoffe und geowissenschaften hier von
der leine zu lassen damit wir uns
konstellationen für rohstoffe weltweit
und vor allen dingen langfristig sichern
und ich hatte zwischenzeitlich wirklich
den eindruck dass sie das auch so sehen
aber deshalb habe ich es überhaupt nicht
verstanden warum sie unseren antrag hier
100 millionen euro für dauerhaft energie
und rohstoffsicherung einzustellen
schlichtweg abgelehnt haben nicht mal
und das hätte man erwarten müssen einen
eigenen antrag haben sich hierzu
eingebracht und deshalb der minister ich
stelle zwar fest dass sie das mediale
geschäft grandios beherrschen sie aber
in der umsetzung noch mehr als gehörig
luft nach oben haben und deshalb dieser
dieser haushalt meine damen und herren
hier ist alles andere als ein zukunft
blicken jahres im gegenteil mit den
durch die koalition und ihr haus
eingebrachten anträge haben sie ihn
leider in keiner weise verbessert man
kann ihn daher nur ablehnen herzlichen
dank
als nächster redner erhält felix paschek
für bündnis 90 grünen dieses wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
hermann feld reden nicht andersrum
machen ist wir reden nur dialer das ist
glaube ich der das ist glaube ich das
ist glaube ich der geist mit dem diese
koalition mit dem robert habeck jetzt
wirtschafts und klimaschutzpolitik
machen und übrigens auch zusammen machen
jeder selbst ja die prioritäten für sich
selbst aber dass sie jetzt ausgerechnet
auf die punkte 1 regale sind in ihrer
rede wo diese koalition liefert ja
beispielsweise dabei dass es die erste
koalition ist die dafür sorgt dass wir
den drittel an scheidet bei
unterstützung des bundes für die
überbetriebliche lehrlingsausbildung
macht selbst nie gemacht sind es immer
angekündigt nie getan wir machen 70
millionen sind jetzt drin
sie haben das thema zimmer angesprochen
und auch hier muss man sich überlegen ob
man wirklich in der richtigen position
ist dass anzugreifen weil wir die
situation vorgefunden haben dass die
vorgängerregierung mit peter altmaier
als bundesminister die mittel so gekürzt
haben dass es zu dem antrag stopp kam
denn diese koalition in der
bereinigungssitzung mit 80 millionen
euro verpflichtungsermächtigungen fürs
kommende jahr aufgelöst hat diese
koalition hat den stoff glitten sie
verursacht haben so ist doch die lage
und
ich muss ihnen gestehen für mich ist das
gerade ein gewisser performative wieder
sport eine performative herausforderung
weil ich seit dem 15 mit sehr gut
gelaunten christdemokratinnen des
christdemokraten über die zukunft
nordrhein westfalen sprechen und ihr da
so schöne sätze im sondierungs papier
vereinbaren konnte ich glaube dass es
ein gemeinsames verständnis gibt die
sagen wir werden die notwendigen
zukunft investitionen tätigen und dafür
instrumente entwickeln und von ihnen
hier im bundestag erleben wir ja nur
destruktion die verhinderung von
investitionen beispielsweise durch die
klage gegen 60 milliarden euro für den
energie und klimafonds und der gipfel
des ganzen ist ja herr kollege mattfeldt
dass ihre ganzen ideen was alles
ausgestattet werden solche im einzelplan
09 und dem energie- und klimafonds der
jetzt der klima und transformations- von
ist sind ja folgende streichens
vorschläge erstens zu streichen weil der
internationalen klimaschutzinitiative
dazu komme ich gleich noch und zweitens
ist ihre gegenfinanzierung das ist
gestern ausgeführt worden ihre
gegenfinanzierung für all die vorschläge
ist die 60 milliarden euro von denen sie
sagen die dürfte es gar nicht geben
jetzt wieder in den haushalt rheins zu
ziehen was hat das mit solider mit
ehrlicher hat wird redlicher
haushaltspolitik zu tun für die sie sich
doch wie vielleicht nehmen sie sich an
den kolleginnen und kollegen nordrhein
westfalen ein beispiel
frau präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen was machten wir mit diesem
haushalt den wir jetzt verändert haben
wir machen war was andere nur
angekündigt haben angela merkel die
bundeskanzlerin hat in der vergangenheit
angekündigt worden sechs milliarden euro
für den internationalen klima und
diversität schaffen ja wir sind diesem
ziel immer noch nicht ganz nah gekommen
aber diese regierung meine damen und
herren ist die erste die überhaupt den
weg dahin beschreiten will die aus den
ankündigungen für den mann dann für die
man dann in den internationalen
konferenzen applaus bekommt auch taten
wachsen dass die priorisiert die ernst
nimmt dass die klima und die
biodiversitäts krise die beiden großen
ökologischen krisen unserer zeit auch
den wohlstand der zukunft bedrohen und
deswegen ist der organisations erlasse
dafür gesorgt hat dass klimaschutz und
wirtschaft endlich kein widerspruch mehr
sind dass das eine ministerium
verhindert dass das andere gerne machen
würde dass es zusammen denkt so ein
quantensprung in der
bundesrepublikanischen politik und ich
kann mir nur wünschen dass wir den weg
weitergehen den wir jetzt beschritten
haben
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
multiple das multiple krisen szenario
vor dem wir stehen erfordert endlich
aufzuhören nur dinge anzukündigen und
erfordert ins handeln zu kommen die
klimakrise die biodiversitäts krise der
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine die vielfältigen
schwerwiegenden auswählt auswirkungen
auf die deutsche wirtschaft auf den
mittelstand die brauchen eben auch die
entsprechende unterstützung und ich
finde man muss auch einfach mal
anerkennen dass es diese regierung ist
und das ist ein grüner bundesminister
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz ist der
die ziele nicht aus dem blick verliert
aber eben im umgang mit diesen krisen im
umgang mit dem dilemma situationen die
wir haben pragmatische wege geht das
bedeutet die versorgungssicherheit jetzt
zu gewährleisten und gleichzeitig den
ambitionierten umstiegs und
transformationsphase in die wege zu
leiten das tun wir mit dem einzelplan
und 9 das tun wir mit dem einzelplan 60
und dem energie- und klimafonds und das
tun wir mit ganz konkreten
regierungshandeln wie jetzt im oster
paket und den einigen wochen dann im
sommer paket ich freue mich auf die
weitere zusammenarbeit in der koalition
in der wir uns auf gute dinge
verständigen konnten und sicherlich noch
viele gute dinge entwickeln werden
vielen dank
nächster redner ist für die afg fraktion
wolfgang diehl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen frühere
debatten über den haushalt des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums handelten
vom richtigen weg zu mehr
wirtschaftswachstum und wohlstand
seit das haus unter grüner führung der
steht geht es hauptsächlich um eine
ideologische transformation von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft die
deutschland und europa im weltmaßstab
weit zurückwerfen wird
es ist kein zufall dass jetzt die
inflation steigt und die aussichten
düster sind der krieg in der ukraine hat
die vorgezeichnete entwicklung los noch
beschleunigt immer mehr bürger aber auch
wirtschaftslenker senken ihre
zukunftserwartungen weil die grüne
politik keine besseren hoffnungen
erlaubt
wenn co2
planziele das maß aller dinge sind und
regelmäßig verschärft werden dann sind
wir mit siebenmeilenstiefeln auf dem weg
in die unproduktive planwirtschaft
nicht nur der haushalt des ministeriums
finanziert das ganze sondern auch der
sogenannte energie und klimafonds rund
10 milliarden euro kommen für staatliche
wirtschaftslenkung zusammen eine 7
milliarden für die einseitige förderung
der e mobilität über eine milliarde für
dekarbonisierung der industrie und auch
hier rund 30 millionen für dinge wie
grünen strahl und das klimaneutrale
schiffen
dass das unsere zukunft sein soll glaubt
das volk nicht von selbst dafür ist viel
propaganda nötig und auch die
politischen hilfstruppen der grünen
werden aus dem haushalt bedient da wird
eine klimaschutzkampagne gefördert
und eine klima allianz genauso selbst
den vom ministerium bezahlten
bürgerdialog stromnetz betreibt ein grün
radikale abmahn verein die sogenannte
deutsche umwelthilfe
diese
nichtregierungsorganisationen oder
besser regierungs hilfsorganisationen
haben große macht nehmen wir zb agora
energiewende dieser verein schlägt vor
künftig unser gasnetz zurückzubauen also
aus dem boden zu reißen sein früherer
direktor patrick reichel ist heute
staatssekretär im ministerium habeck und
wiederholt diese forderung im namen der
regierung
was heißt das für unser land ich nenne
das energiewende brutal wenn man später
nämlich merkt dass diese energiewende in
richtung steinzeit führt ist die brücke
auf dem rückweg schon abgerissen
[Applaus]
genau dieselbe strategie verfolgt die
regierung mit der zerstörung der co2
freien kernenergie die afg verfolgt
einen völlig anderen weg wir fordern
eine energie sicherheits wende in
zukunft muss die energieversorgung
wieder sicher seien dazu gehören
kernenergie gas öl und kohle und genauso
wind und sonne
es darf keine sanktionen geben die
deutschland am meisten schaden wenn
ungarns ministerpräsident orban für
seine bürger durchsetzt dass die eu
alleine weiter fließen lässt dann muss
deutschland das nutzen statt ablehnen
diese haltung herr minister habeck ist
arrogant und verkauft deutsche
interessen
damit deutschland eine gute zukunft hat
brauchen wir keine energie oder
verkehrswende sondern eine politikwende
der ideologen geldspeicher namens
energie und klimafonds muss aufgelöst
werden die bürger müssen auch künftig
sich das autofahren und das heizen
leisten können dann würde man wieder von
politik für den wohlstand reden und das
fordern wir von der fdp
[Applaus]
es folgt für die spd-fraktion der
kollege frank junge
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren viele angesichts ihrer immer
wieder und permanent vorgetragenen
kruden ansichten bin ich ganz froh
darüber dass die leute in
wahlergebnissen ausdrücken was sie auch
politisch von ihnen halten und das
dokumentieren ja auch gerade die
jüngsten wahlen die an dieser stelle
stattgefunden haben
in diesen zeiten des verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg putin auf die ukraine in
den zeiten in dem wir die korona krise
noch lange nicht überwunden haben und in
den zeiten in denen wir vor
existenziellen und
generationenübergreifenden
zukunftsaufgaben stehen ist es aus
meiner sicht wichtig dass der
stabilitäts- schafft und
handlungsfähigkeit bewahrt und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen genau das
dokumentiert der einzelplan des
wirtschaftsministeriums genau das ist es
was wir vorlegen dann stellen wir das
kennen wir nicht nur die notwendigen
mittel bereit um die äußere innere
sicherheit und auch die soziale
sicherzustellen wir eröffnen damit auch
ein jahrzehnt der investitionen in
größenordnungen um die zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres landes zu gewährleisten darauf
kommt es an damit wir im globalen
maßstab die wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer
wirtschaft sichern zusammen mit den
verstärkung mitteln aus dem ktf sind
jetzt insgesamt 11 milliarden euro auf
dem tisch und wir haben sie an dieser
stelle natürlich eingesetzt und den
klimaschutz voranzutreiben die
transformation von industrie wirtschaft
und mobilität voran zu führen die
weiterentwicklung der
wasserstoffwirtschaft voranzubringen
innovationsförderung vorzunehmen und
auch strukturschwäche im land weiter zu
begleiten
all das war uns in der ampelkoalition
wichtig all das findet sich auch im
rahmen dieses haushalts wieder und zudem
sichern wir eine gasversorgung die viel
breiter aufgestellt ist als bisher wir
bauen eine lng infrastruktur aus wir
bauen die erneuerbaren energien aus und
schaffen damit endlich einen übergang in
eine energieversorgung die uns
unabhängig von preisentwicklungen derart
macht wie wir sie jetzt haben und auch
das ist etwas was der wirtschaft in
unglaublichem maße zugute kommt
natürlich war es uns als ampel
haushälter wichtig die großen linien aus
dem koalitionsvertrag zu bedienen das
ist hier an der stelle auch von felix ja
schon gestrichen worden also wenn wir
hier über die energetische
gebäudesanierung sprechen mit elf
milliarden euro sind das wahnsinnig
wichtige komplexe die dekarbonisierung
der industrie ist damit rinne die tank
und ladeinfrastruktur
die digitalisierung der wirtschaft alter
sind milliardenbeträge die genau dort
angesetzt werden können wo sie nicht nur
für die umstellung unserer wirtschaft im
rahmen des transformationsprozesses gilt
sie sind auch wichtig dafür um impulse
zu setzen wirtschaftliche anreize zu
vollziehen um und am ende damit auch
wirtschaftswachstum zu generieren
wir haben dazu auch im einzelplan 09 die
automobilindustrie weiter gestärkt die
luft und raumfahrt und auch den
schiffbau auf hohem niveau verstetigt
und wir haben an der stelle auch dafür
gesorgt dass wir eigene akzente setzen
und lieber kollege matt fällt das muss
ich jetzt dann doch auch noch mal sagen
du hast beklagt dass wir eure anträge
nicht zur kenntnis genommen oder sogar
umgesetzt haben das liegt einfach daran
dass wir uns in der einzelplan beratung
für 200 millionen euro ungedeckte
schecks vorgelegt habt ohne jeglichen
ansatz einer deckung und in der
bereinigungssitzung habt ihr dort
grössenordnungen im rahmen der deckung
aufgezeigt felix hat es gesagt die
bedeutet hätten die deckung aus dem egf
den er beklagt hervor zu nehmen und dass
es an der stelle so absurd und unlogisch
und in meiner ansicht auch verantwortung
wir haben mit den akzenten die wir
gesetzt haben ganz besonders wert darauf
gelegt die kleinen mittelständischen
unternehmen zu unterstützen tim ist ein
beispiel dafür
die die 20 millionen erhöhung ist dort
ein ganz wichtiger baustein und wir
haben an der stelle auch dafür gesorgt
dass wir mit der
verpflichtungsermächtigung von 80
millionen euro für das nächste jahr
nicht wieder in ein loch fallen so wie
es die haushaltsplanung von peter
altmaier jetzt gebracht hatte die
industrieforschung ist ein weiterer
bestandteil dafür die kleinen
unternehmen zu stärken und wenn ich noch
zwei punkte nennen darf dann will ich
vor allen dingen die grw nennen die
gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
wirtschaftsstruktur ist etwas was
insbesondere strukturschwachen regionen
hilft und unsere auf besserung um
weitere 25 millionen euro hilft genau
dort wo es dringend benötigt wird 80
prozent dieser mittel fließen dazu noch
in den osten wo im rahmen der
angleichung der lebensverhältnisse noch
viel geleistet werden muss und das ist
ein punkt der uns ganz wichtig war und
der zu herauszustellen ist und letzter
punkt den ich hier noch handle das ist
der und dann begreife ich auch gar nicht
andreas wie du das kritisieren kannst
wir haben den aufwuchs der
überbetrieblichen lehrlingsausbildung
vorgenommen damit ist das handwerk
glücklich genauso glücklich darüber dass
wir fünf millionen mehr für die
investition in die in die
bildungsinfrastruktur für das handwerk
gegeben haben das sind alles maßnahmen
die dokumentieren ganz klar und vor
allen dingen auch mit deckungs vermerken
untersetzt was wir vorhaben wo unsere
schwerpunkte liegen und wie wichtig uns
diese entwicklung sind liebe kolleginnen
und ich komme zum schluss der einzelplan
09 stellt nicht nur wie ich finde ein
verantwortungsvolles herangehen an die
globalen krisen da den dem wir uns
stellen müssen wir bringen damit mit
diesem etat auch die energie wärme und
mobilitäts wende weiter voran wir nehmen
damit unsere unternehmen mit besetzten
anreiz und impulse wir schaffen es so
sie zu stärken und wir sichern an dieser
stelle auf diese art und weise natürlich
verlässlichkeit und planungssicherheit
und wir schaffen somit auch ein stück
weit beschäftigung und weiteren
wohlstand deshalb bitte ich sie um
zustimmung zu diesem haushalt
sagt franke junge aus der spd-fraktion
der zuvor den blick auf kleine
unternehmen und auch in die regionen
gerichtet hatte in dieser debatte in der
es um den etat für das ministerium für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz geht und da
spricht jetzt victor perli aus der links
fraktion sprecher für umverteilung
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin sind
meine damen und herren die menschen in
unserem land müssen die steigenden
preise bei energie und lebensmitteln
die hohe inflation teuer bezahlen auch
mittelschicht familien müssen sich
einschränken wir angst vor der
heizkostenabrechnung ist groß wir
steuern auf eine armutsfalle zu wie sie
dieses land noch nicht gesehen hat wer
ist schon vor dem krieg schwer hatte
über die runden zu kommen weiß heute
nicht wovon er am ende des monats leben
soll wir sehen das daran dass die
schlangen vor den tafeln immer länger
werden und die ampel koalition
beschließt hier einen haushalt für die
lebenswirklichkeit
dieser millionen menschen ignoriert und
keine gerechtigkeit schafft das ist
wirklich beschämend meine damen und
herren
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat schwarz auf
weiß bestätigt was die linke von anfang
an gesagt hat die an position lässt vor
allem rentner menschen mit geringen
einkommen und die ärmsten im stich die
forscher haben nachgewiesen dass der
groß der größte teil ihrer
entlastungspaket
ausgerechnet bei den menschen landet die
die höchsten einkommen haben die reichen
die am wenigsten hilfe brauchen bekommen
die meiste unterstützung und diejenigen
die am wenigsten haben und am meisten
unterstützung brauchen bekommen am
wenigsten unterstützung dass das
gegenteil von gerechtigkeit
spd grüne und fdp müssen hier
beantworten wie zu dieser
ungerechtigkeit kommen konnte weil es
ihre absicht
weil es ein versehen
so oder so zeigt es dass in dieser
position das soziale gewissen nicht
vorhanden ist meine damen und herren
auf den wahlplakaten stand respekt und
gerechtigkeit im haushalt wird sich
nichts davon es ist respektlos dass
rentner und studierende keine 300 euro
energie pauschale bekommen
[Applaus]
er habe
vor den tafeln wenn ich langen länger da
stehen renten die kinder jetzt sehen wir
die rente nicht ausreicht
finden sie es nicht beschämend dass die
minister
300 euro pauschale bekommen und die
rentner leer ausgehen ist ihnen das
nicht meine damen und herren
sorgen sie dafür dass auch die
studierenden ist auch die rentner diese
pauschale endlich bekommen
aktuell sehen wir an den tankstellen
dass die ölkonzerne sich bereichern sie
haben kurz vor der steuersenkung erst
mal kräftig die preise angehoben und die
ampel-koalition schaut tatenlos zu wie
sich dann
auf kosten der begründung bürgern die
taschen voll gemacht werden es gibt ein
bundeskartellamt dafür ist er habe
zuständig das gibt verhaltenstipps wie
man sich verhalten soll anstatt
einzugreifen dafür zu sorgen dass diese
steuer sind eins zu eins an kommt bei
den menschen
wir fordern eine wirksame preisaufsicht
und einem übergewicht und hatten diesen
profiteure damit diejenigen die hier
abzocken auch dann damit belegt werden
damit sich abzocke nicht lohnt das geld
muss mit den bürgern angekommen und ich
finde auch letzter satz sollten es doch
hier einig sein kein mensch sollte angst
oder heizkostenabrechnung haben vielen
dank
victor perli aus der linksfraktion mit
fragen an den bundeswirtschaftsminister
in diesem fall zu einer pauschale für
sendener antworten darauf möglicherweise
nach den beiden nächsten rednern dann
jedenfalls steht der
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
auf der rednerliste jetzt aber erstmal
karsten klein ob man für die fdp im
haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen anfang der
woche hat die eu ein weiteres
sanktionspaket gegen russland auf den
weg gebracht ich denke das begrüßen wir
alle ausdrücklich aber klar muss auch
sein dass sanktionen dass unser
sanktionsregime dazu führen vor allem
die russische seite die russische
wirtschaft mehr zu schädigen als die
europäische oder die deutsche und dass
unsere sanktionen wirken sieht man auch
daran dass hochwertige güter aus europa
und deutschland der russischen
wirtschaft nicht mehr zur verfügung
steht hochwertige güter die durch andere
staaten die sich an den sanktionen nicht
beteiligen nur schwer zu substituieren
sind das zeigt aber auch noch mal liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was wir an
stärke in diesem konflikt mit einbringen
in die waagschale mit einbringen können
nämlich unsere wirtschaftliche stärke
die möglichkeit dass die menschen in
diesem land ihr know how in güter in
hochwertige dienstleistungen
transferieren können auch für die
freunde in der ukraine und deshalb
deshalb hat die ampel koalition die zwei
kollegen sind ja schon darauf
eingegangen auch noch mal massiv an den
mitteln zugelegt um innovationskraft um
die zukunftsfähigkeit um das know how
dieser menschen zu stärken hier in
diesem land über die berufliche bildung
über das zentrale mittelstandsprogramm
innovation und andere töpfe genau um das
zu erreichen dass wir wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben international und dass wir diese
stärke auch noch in diesem konflikt
einbringen können
die kolleginnen kollegen das gegenteil
von dem die wirtschaftskraft zu
verstärken wäre es gewesen der forderung
nach einem sofortigen gas in waben
nachzukommen
die preise sind für die bürgerinnen
bürgern den letzten wochen extrem
gestiegen an der tankstelle bis zu 40
prozent in der spitze beim gas sogar
fast verdoppelt aber das ist nur ein
müder vorgeschmack von dem was passieren
würde wenn wir ein sofortiges
gas-embargo von verhängen würden und ja
es war eine fehlentscheidung sich so
massiv von russischer energie abhängig
zu machen aber deshalb muss es für uns
gelten gegenstrategien zu entwickeln und
es hat diese bundesregierung getan das
hat diese bundesregierung getan
jetzt um einen kurzfristig die bürger
den bürgern bei der groß gestiegenen
energiepreisen eine abdämpfen
ermöglichen über das entlastungspaket 37
milliarden euro in der summe über die
abschaffung der gng umlage zum beispiel
oder über den tank rabatt und herr
minister ich bin überzeugt davon dass
sie mit dem kartellamt gemeinsam dafür
sorge tragen werden dass diese preis ab
sendung auch bei den bürgerinnen und
bürgern ankommen wir haben
wir haben es aber auch getan indem wir
einen zuschuss bei ihnen einzelplan
eingestellt haben mit vier milliarden
euro für die energieintensive wirtschaft
und das zeigt kurzfristig haben wir
schon reagiert aber natürlich sport darf
es auch einer mittelfristig und
langfristigen strategie um die
abhängigkeit von fossiler russische
energie zu reduzieren und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union da
ist natürlich der vorschlag 750
milliarden euro bei der dekarbonisierung
der industrie zu streichen genau das
gegenteil von dem eine strategie zu
entwickeln um die abhängigkeit zu
reduzieren
wir als koalition haben aber in den
haushalt aufgenommen um die abhängigkeit
zu erreichen zum einen investitionen in
infrastruktur bei lg ich begrüße
ausdrücklich dass es hier auch eine
kehrtwende gegeben hat fast vier
milliarden euro für die schwimmenden
plattform und löst um das flüssiggas
auch in unsere systeme zu bringen das
dient natürlich der reduzierung der
abhängigkeit und das dient der
versorgungssicherheit wir dürfen aber in
diesem zusammenhang nicht die
versorgungs preise außer acht lassen und
deshalb müssen wir den menschen auch
sagen in den letzten zehn jahren war
fred bahr allen tigers immer 30 prozent
teurer als das gas aus den pipelines und
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herr minister muss es uns gelingen den
spiri die idee unseres
koalitionsvertrags auch noch stärker zu
leben wir wollen über innovationen über
fortschritt zu weniger verbrauch kommen
und dazu dass wir uns neue
energiequellen erschließen das sind die
aufgaben für die nächsten monate und
jahre
und natürlich müssen wir auch dafür
sorgen dass die mittel im haushalt ihre
wirksamkeit
besser wir haben eine ganze reihe von
rechnungshof berichten und da hat ihnen
ihr vorgänger peter altmaier und die
union ja herr minister leider eine
riesenbaustelle wir lassen diese
rechnungshofberichte lägen noch mal fest
dass wir eine sehr schlechte
koordination haben wenn es um die mittel
in der energiewende geht dass wir keine
schlechte wirksamkeit haben bei der
verausgabung dieser mit die wir haben
hohe ausgabereste im bereich des
wirtschaftsministeriums und des energie
und klimafonds und deshalb gilt es das
hat die koalition auch beschlossen dass
wir diese wirksamkeit der mittel erhöhen
denn wir wollen alle gemeinsam erreichen
dass wir nicht mittel in den haushalt
einstellen sondern das g co2 einsparen
und dass wir uns alternative
energiequellen eröffnen und das muss das
ziel der nächsten monat das seien vielen
dank wir auch nicht hinter
karsten klein war das für die
fdp-fraktion obmann im ausschuss für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz
jetzt jens spahn stellvertretender
vorsitzender der cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die inflation ist auf
rekordniveau der wirtschaftliche
ausblick trübt sich einen eine
stagnation droht die energieversorgung
ist gefährdet in zeiten wie diesen wäre
es gut wenn der wirtschafts und
energieminister einen plan mit klaren
prioritäten vorlegen würde aber in allzu
vielen bereichen und ich will drei
nennen fehlt ein solcher plan erstens zu
innovations- und strukturpolitik gerade
in zeiten der inflation braucht es eine
wachstumsfördernde politik denn wachstum
weitet das angebot aus und dämpft damit
die inflation ein der bundesminister der
finanzen hat ein papier für eine
wachstumsfördernde angebotspolitik
vorgelegt bürokratie abbauen
zumindest die fdp freut sich in der
koalition reber bürokratieabbau und
arbeitsrecht flexibilisieren anreize für
investitionen setzen zum beispiel so ein
papier der wirtschaftsminister hätten
wir uns auch von ihnen gewünscht denn
nur wenn sie die beiden sich einig sind
finanz und wirtschaftsminister dann
kommt eine wachstumspolitik auch
zustande schiller und strauss das waren
plisch und plum habeck und lindner das
ist eher wie monterrey wie katz und maus
aber wird das ist unterhaltsam was wir
brauchen es aber nicht ein katz und maus
spiel was wir brauchen ist ein
kohärentes konzept von finanz- und
wirtschaftspolitik in diesen zeiten
gestern sagten sie rezession vermeiden
kaufkraft erhalten gerechtigkeit walten
lassen das sei das ziel alles nette
überschriften alles soweit richtig aber
was will diese regierung konkret
in zeiten von rekord inflation
und unsicherheit in der wirtschaft tun
die bürgerinnen und bürger und ja auch
dieses parlament haben einen anspruch
darauf endlich mal einen kohärenten plan
zu bekommen gleich haben sie die
gelegenheit dazu er minister
ein zweites beispiel ist die
energiepolitik
wir seien sehr gut vorbereitet falls wir
kein russisches gas im winter bekommen
sagen wirtschaftsminister um kanzler den
eindruck habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht der deutsche bundestag hat vor
zwei monaten vor zwei monaten mit
stimmen von spd union grünen und fdp die
bundesregierung aufgefordert einen
ausstiegsfahrplan vorzulegen mal genau
darzulegen jenseits von interviews und
einzelnen äußerungen wie viel
terawattstunden etwa an energie aus gas
wie er bis wann ersetzen wollen bei den
russischen lieferungen durch was bis
jetzt haben wir dazu keinen konkreten
plan ist sie es vor zwei monaten
kurzfristig kämen lieferungen aus katar
gas jetzt heißt es ist kein 2024 werden
nichts genaues weiß man nicht
gasspeicher sie haben ein gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt um kohle sie haben einen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt zum glas stoff
und sagen
kohlekraftwerke sollen möglicherweise am
netz bleiben auch braunkohlekraftwerke
bemerkenswerterweise um dann im fall der
fälle einzuspringen warum nicht jetzt
schon eigentlich müssten wir doch schon
nur das sagen wir seit zwei monaten seit
wochen stärker kohlekraftwerke nutzen in
dieser zeit um gas zu sparen bei den
gaskraftwerken und die speicher zu
füllen während sie uns vor zwei monaten
gefolgt hätten wir hier schon 23 prozent
von der rega speichern
kollegen und
den übrigen verstehe ich auch nicht bis
heute nicht auch in der aktuellen
debatte warum ein grüner klimaminister
lieber kohle auch pro
braunkohlekraftwerke im fall der fälle
am netz lässt als co2 neutrale
kernkraftwerke die noch laufen weiter
laufen zu lassen das will mir nicht in
den sinn und hermann acker zu recht
darauf hingewiesen und wir unterstützen
sie dabei haben mehrfach zugestimmt sie
sind an vielen stellen pragmatisch und
tun dinge die sie sonst nicht getan
hätten und das ist anzuerkennen und das
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich aber es
wäre eben auch gut wenn sie in dieser
frage pragmatismus und nicht ideologie
walten ließen die aktuelle situation
erfordert ist jedenfalls liebe
kolleginnen
ein drittes beispiel die handelspolitik
sie haben gesagt energiepolitik ist
sicherheitspolitik unter stimmt auch
handelspolitik ist sicherheitspolitik
das hat drei dimensionen die globale
dimension freihandel wird gegen armut
verbindet uns mit der welt und mit den
partnern die unsere werte teilen
die dimension der versorgungssicherheit
freihandel mit verschiedenen
verlässlichen partnern steigert die
resilienz unserer lieferkette und
drittens auch die dimensionen unsere
unternehmen und beschäftigten freihandel
sichert in deutschland etwa viereinhalb
millionen arbeitsplätze und damit auf
das einkommen von millionen familien und
auch da könnten sie ein wichtiges
zeichen setzen wir setzen es jede woche
hier auf zur abstimmung während sie gas
in katar und ägypten richtigerweise
kaufen verweigern sie bis heute dem
freihandel mit kanada die zustimmung
hier im deutschen bundestag die fdp
selbst die minister der fdp fordern
mittlerweile öffentlich die zustimmung
wir fordern sie auf in zeiten wie diesen
lassen sie uns endlich das
handelsabkommen mit kanada ratifizieren
und eine zustimmung die im deutschen
bundestag erreichen
man muss man muss nur herrn
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann in
dieser frage folgen mit dem stimmen wir
davon ist überhaupt kein problem ich
verstehe gar nicht warum an bestimmten
stellen so viel pragmatismus möglich ist
richtigerweise und an anderen stellen
dann wieder geologie überwiegt wir
müssen alle in zeiten wie diesen ein
würde auch bereit an vielen stellen und
reichen die hand dazu mit denen
zusammenzuarbeiten
aber sie müssen sie auch schon ertragen
wir sind staatstragend in zeiten wie
diesen aber wir sind nicht regierungs
tragen zu müssen schon damit rechnen in
diesen zeiten das ist kritik gibt für
das was sie tun oder eben nicht tun
und frau präsidentin abschließend
steuereinnahmen halten das land am
laufen haben es haben sie kürzlich
gesagt der wirtschaftsminister so
ähnlich wie der strom kommt aus der
steckdose oder die milch kommt aus dem
supermarkt denn strom muss produziert
werden bauern müssen die kühe melken und
das geld des staates das kommt nicht vom
finanzamt steuereinnahmen müssen erst
einmal erwirtschaften es sind die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
die das land am laufen halten und das
ist wichtig immer wieder auch zu zeigen
und deutlich zu machen denn das drückt
eine geisteshaltung aus die wir in der
steuerpolitik reden wir über die frage
reden woher das geld kommt und wie wir
mit dem geld umgehen drückt eine
geisteshaltung aus den zeiten wie diesen
halten wir es für wichtig genau das
anzuerkennen und zurückzukehren zur
haushaltskonsolidierung die richtigen
schwerpunkte zu setzen und eine politik
für wachstum zu haben in zeiten der
hohen inflation dazu reichen wir ihnen
gerne die hand
allerlei vorwürfe des früheren
gesundheitsministers und jetzigen
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
unionsfraktion jens spahn an den
bundeswirtschaftsminister er solle etwa
pragmatismus statt ideologie walten
lassen die gegenrede vom minister selbst
vielen dank der präsidentin sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kollege sparen
geisteshaltung geologie biologie vorwurf
würde ich sagen muss sich derjenigen
gefallen lassen der den billigen applaus
zuliebe hier phrasen verkündet ohne die
konkrete wirklichkeit die handlung und
die entwicklung in der wirklichkeit zur
kenntnis zu nehmen
auf die wirklichkeit zu kommen
dieser haushalt und die debatte die wir
führen ist ein besonderer haushalt vor
einer besonderen wirklichkeit viele
aspekte und ich kann in fünf minuten die
ich habe nicht auf alle eingehen sind
genannt worden die das land besonders
bedrückend aber es hat natürlich einen
grund warum diese bedrückung das und
dieser grund ist der angriffskrieg der
durch nichts zu rechtfertigende
angriffskrieg von putin auf die ukraine
der tod der menschen der dort verursacht
wird und die hohen kosten die druck auf
den bevölkerungen auf die wirtschaft die
wir hier zu tragen haben sehr geehrte
damen und herren aber wir sagen sie
erfolgreich der bundeskanzler hat
gestern aufgelistet welche waffen und
welche waffengattung die bundesrepublik
deutschland der ukraine zur verfügung
stellt ich möchte kurz darauf eingehen
dass wir uns ebenfalls an einem anderen
konflikt befinden nämlich einem
wirtschafts konflikt wir schauen und
diskutieren wenn wir auf die
sanktionsliste schauen immer über die öl
und die bars verkäufe die russland noch
immer tätigt und ja die einnahmen die
putin
erzielt hat in den letzten monaten durch
die hohen preise sie sind die tun weh
und man kann sich dafür eigentlich nur
schämen dass wir es immer noch nicht
geschafft haben diese abhängigkeit
deutlich zu reduzieren aber
nur auf die einnahmen auf die öl- und
gaseinnahmen von putin zu schauen
verkennt was gerade die wirklichkeit ist
eine wirklichkeit wir mit mit den
alliierten zusammen herstellen er kann
sich nämlich von dem geld das er
verdient immer weniger ja faktisch
nichts mehr kaufen die russische
wirtschaft bricht ein die exporte nach
russland die importe nach russland für
die russische seite sie gehen dramatisch
zurück
insgesamt sind die exporte der
alliierten derjenigen die sich den
sanktionen angeschlossen haben in den
letzten monaten um 53 prozent
zurückgegangen wichtiger vielleicht noch
dass auch die exporte aus den ländern
die neutral oder sogar prorussisch
aufgestellt sind um 45 prozent
zurückgegangen sind
deutschland mit einem anteil eines
exportrückgangs nach russland um minus
60 prozent allein im märz wie erwartet
eine deutlich höhere zahl im april hat
einen wesentlichen anteil daran dass es
so ist und diese exportrückgang er ist
ja das haben wir bei corona gemerkt da
ist ja nicht in der allgemeinheit nur zu
erfassen denn was dann fehlt sind teile
in spezifischen die verkehrten die
russische wirtschaft bis ins mark
treffen wird es fehlen
sicherheitsupdates für die flugzeuge mit
der konsequenz dass bald die flugzeuge
am boden bleiben es fehlen technische
güter
value kurth in der technischen kette die
die produktionsprozesse zerstören werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren
putin kriegt noch geld aber er kann es
kaum noch aufgeben und die zeit sie
arbeitet nicht für russland sie arbeitet
gegen russland sie arbeitet gegen die
russische wirtschaft die russische
wirtschaft ist eingebrochen das bild ist
um 9 prozent zurückgegangen die
kreditwürdigkeit russland ist
ramschstatus die investitionstätigkeit
ist um 34 prozent zurückgegangen niemand
will mehr in russland investieren da
kann das nicht mehr lange durchhalten er
kann vielleicht so eine armee noch
versorgen mit den möglichkeiten die
haben england hat öl und weizen aber die
russische wirtschaft ist hart getroffen
durch die sanktionen und einen
wesentlichen teil davon trägt die
deutsche wirtschaft und dass sie das tut
das kann man nur mit dank sagen
beantworten
einen wesentlichen teil bekommt
die deutsche bevölkerung
wir haben über die hohen belastungen
gesprochen und auch da muss man sagen
danke dafür denn wir tun ist ja nicht
aus spaß wir tun ist um die russische
und die putins wirtschaft zu schädigen
und so unseren beitrag unseren
wirtschaftspolitischen beitrag zu
leisten dass dieser krieg irgendwann ein
ende findet in dem wir die russische
wirtschaft bis ins mark treffen werden
und wir sind dabei ist zu tun dann gerät
er erlaubt eine zwischenfrage aus der
afg fraktion
einige damen und herren das hat
konsequenzen für mein ministerium und
für den haushalt wir haben in einer
großen geschwindigkeit neue gesetze
schreiben müssen sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz die sanktion zu kontrollieren
dass energie sicherungs gesetz das elend
beschleunigungsgesetz das kohlereserven
erst das speicher geist spielt das gas
speicher gesetzt die verordnung die
heute dazu führt dass reden jetzt auch
pflicht mäßig erfüllt wird die
waffenexporte müssen kontrolliert werden
die hilfsprogramme strukturiert und
verausgabt werden dazu natürlich die
arbeit eine energiewende und an den
strukturellen aufgaben die wir insgesamt
haben dass das im haushalt
nachgezeichnet wird dafür möchte ich
mich ausdrücklich bedanken für die guten
konstruktiven gespräch es ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass das parlament
das sieht ich möchte mich aber auch
bedanken bei der verwaltung jetzt
stellvertretend bei meinem haus letzter
satz man sagt ja immer die verwaltung
die planungsprozesse alles zu langsam
alles zu träge wir zeigen in einer
gemeinschaftlichen anstrengung in diesem
jahr von unternehmen und wirtschaft von
bürgerinnen und bürgern aber auch von
der verwaltung wie leistungsfähig unser
land und unsere demokratie ist der
haushalt sieht mit dass ab vielen dank
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
am ende noch mit einem blick nach quasi
hinter die kulissen in dem er sich auch
noch mal an sein haus gerichtet hat denn
es gibt vieles auf den weg zu bringen in
diesen tagen wenn es gelingen soll das
wie er sagt die russische wirtschaft bis
ins mark getroffen werden soll
beispielsweise durch wirtschaftliche
sanktionen und das hat natürlich auch
hierzulande konsequenzen enrico corning
für die fdp fraktion ist wenn historiker
auf der tribüne wir lieben in
deutschland gegenwärtig ein von der
alten großen koalition angelegten und
von der ampelkoalition
fortgeführten beispielslosen
wirtschaftlichen niedergang in
deutschland erst gestern musste ich am
hauptbahnhof sehen wie ein rentner im
müll umhüllte und sich die pfandflaschen
heraussuchte um sein lebensunterhalt zu
erhalten menschen die ein leben lang
gearbeitet haben können von ihrer rente
können von ihren ersparnissen nicht mehr
leben dass es eine schande wie konnte
wie konnte es soweit kommen wie konnte
es so weit kommen dass die bürger dieses
landes ihren strom nicht mehr bezahlen
können und dass eine warme wohnung zum
luxusgut wird es ist ihre bewusst
herbeigeführte zumindest bewusst in kauf
genommene inflation ihre reihe ideologie
betriebene vollkommen wirkungslose und
darüber hinaus umwelt zerstörende
energiewende ihre mittelstandsfeindlich
wirtschaftspolitik und nicht zuletzt ihr
historisches taumeln durch die korona
zeit nicht schuld nicht schuld herr h
weg ist hingegen der ukraine krieg an
sich den sie doch nur dazu nutzen um
ihre fatale wirtschaftspolitik zu
rechtfertigen
sie legen hier einen schuldenhaushalt
einen weiteren schuldenhaushalt vor
diesmal sind es 100 milliarden netto
neuverschuldung leidtragende sind die
mittelständische wirtschaft und die
leistungsträger der gesellschaft nämlich
die arbeitnehmer ganze zehn milliarden
das sind nicht einmal zwei prozent des
gesamthaushaltes fallen in den bereich
wirtschaft
als vormals stellvertretender
verwaltungsratsvorsitzender
dass der steuerzahler in mecklenburg
vorpommern weiß ich wie der staat
steuern zum fenster heraus wirft was sie
aber machen lässt einen nur noch
ungläubig staunend da finanzieren sie
aus dem wirtschafts haushalts
sozialunternehmen unternehmen ohne
gewinnerzielungsabsicht
unternehmen die nichts aber auch gar
nichts zum wachstum von beschäftigung
und gesellschaftlichen wohlstand
beitragen das können sie von mir aus ja
machen aber nehmen sie doch dann bitte
die mittel aus dem sozial- oder
kulturbudget und dann wiederum streichen
sie ein investitionsprogramm für die
automobilzulieferindustrie zusammen um
fast 200 millionen ein programm das
eigentlich zur zukunftsfähigkeit der von
ihnen geschliffenen deutschen
vorzeigebranche gedacht war blanker hohn
für zigtausende arbeitnehmer und ihre
familien
meine damen und herren
deutschland verarmt vor ihren augen und
sie führen deutschland zielsicher in
eine erbarmungslose
planwirtschaft anstatt gestaltungs
kräfte zu entfesseln und als ehemaliges
fdp-mitglied will ich zumindest an
diesem teil der regierung appelieren
beenden sie diesen ganzen unsinn kehren
sie zurück zur freiheit
chancengleichheit und anstand vielen
dank
der bundestag diskutiert über den
einzelplan 09 eben bundeshaushalt 20 22
das ist der etat für das ministerium für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz 11,33
milliarden euro soll es ausgeben können
und jetzt der wirtschaftspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion bernd westphal
dazu
zeitgleich zu unserer debatte die wir
hier führen tobt ein erbarmungsloser
schrecklicher krieg in europa der
angriff der feige angriff russlands der
krieg von putin auf die menschen in der
ukraine ist erbärmlich dass wir etwas im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert erleben
müssen ist etwas was wir uns alle kaum
vorstellen können und deshalb werden wir
alles dafür tun die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer in ihren mutigen kampf dagegen
zu unterstützen wir werden alles dafür
tun dieses land in dieser zeit nicht
alleine zu lassen und deshalb ist es
richtig das was olaf scholz ihr am
mittwoch in seiner regierungserklärung
gesagt hat alles was jetzt notwendig ist
werden wir für die ukraine tun meine
damen und herren
und natürlich heißt das auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen für die
folgen das sanktionspaket was mit
unseren europäischen partnern und
innerhalb der nato vereinbart worden ist
hat massive auswirkungen auf russland
der wirtschaftsminister hat eben darauf
hingewiesen aber natürlich auch auf die
deutsche wirtschaft und deshalb kann man
sagen dass wir nicht gegen die
wirtschaft sondern wer am sonntag bei
der eröffnung der hannover messe dabei
war konnte das vom präsidenten des
verbandes der deutschen maschinen und
anlagenbauern herrn huisken hören die
wirtschaft steht hinter dieser
bundesregierung ich würde mir wünschen
dass die opposition in so schwierigen
zeiten das auch tun würde herzlichen
dank für dieses votum
wir befinden uns in einer schwierigen
situation das weiß jeder aber dennoch am
messe rundgang am montag in hannover und
schon zum 75 mal findet die stadt in
dieser industrie schaue wo
internationale firmen in deutschland
ihre produkte zeigen wo die
innovationskraft der deutschen
wirtschaft sichtbar wird dort war zu
spüren dass die unternehmen sich auf den
weg machen mitzuhelfen mit ihren
technologien eine klimaneutrale
wirtschaft zu organisieren zu gucken
dass wir mobilität dass wir heizen dass
ihr prozesswärme dass wir die
stromerzeugung dass wir wasserstoff
produzieren das sind innovationen die
dort sichtbar sind und die unternehmen
haben nicht geklagt ersparen über zu
hohe löhne oder dass wir zuviel
arbeitsschutz hätten oder zu viel
mitbestimmung nein ganz im gegenteil
das erste argument was genannt worden
ist wir brauchen fachkräfte in diesem
land und dafür wird dieser
bundeshaushalt sorgen dass wir gerade
die mittel was die ausbildung der krach
arbeiten angeht verstärken dass wir
gerade willkommenskultur entwickelt das
menschen mit kräften hier nach
deutschland kommen das ist das was
hätten sie sich überzeugen können wenn
sie den rundgang gemacht hätten und
nicht das was sie machen das was die
ideologie der union ist wenn sie über
bürokratieabbau sprechen dann heißt das
schleifen von arbeitnehmerrechten und
lohndrückerei und das werden wir nicht
mitmachen
und deshalb
deshalb ist es zum beispiel richtig wenn
wir inflation über sieben prozent haben
dass sie mit einem großen maßnahmepaket
energiepreise dementsprechend entlasten
aber auch mit dem mindestlohngesetz
dafür sorgen dass wir lohnerhöhungen von
teilweise 30 prozent im
niedriglohnsektor haben sechs millionen
menschen werden in diesem land davon
profitieren und deshalb ist das richtig
dass wir dieses gesetz auf den weg
bringen um die kaufkraft zu erhöhen das
steuert dagegen es schafft stabilität in
unserer wirtschaft
das was der haushalt auch macht und die
gesetze mit rosa paket und das was noch
zu erwarten ist aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium zeigte
das ist ja spaß macht in einer
bundesregierung mit ab mitzuarbeiten und
ich habe ja acht jahre
energiepolitik mit verantwortet für
meine fraktion dass es spaß macht jetzt
genau diese transformation zu gestalten
erneuerbare energien auszubauen
kommunen und länder zu stärken im
genehmigungsverfahren schneller zu
werden eine aufbruch situation zu
erzeugen genau das ist der investive
teil denn diese bundesregierung jetzt
als signal sendet und genau das ist
etwas was unser land und unsere
wirtschaft zukunftsfähig macht und nicht
zaudern und bremsen das ist gott sei
dank jetzt vorbei die ampel ist
innovativer in dieser regierung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die wirtschaft mit diesen
herausforderungen ist gestärkt die
rahmenbedingungen die wir als
bundesregierung setzen sind genau diese
innovationstreiber wir sind investitions
und innovations- unterstützer und
förderer das zeigt der bundeshaushalt
zum beispiel mit einem sehr
erfolgreichen instrument der zukunft
investitionen für den mittelstand das
zimmer krebs wird noch einmal mit
mitteln erhöht es ist ein programm was
abgefragt wird was in den unternehmen
auch anerkannt ist die mittel werden
abgerufen und fördern genau diese
innovationskraft die wir brauchen auch
übrigens in einem internationalen
wettbewerb wir merken dass dass wir auch
international auf den märkten mit diesen
produkten erfolgreich sind gleichzeitig
fordern wir die industrielle
gemeinschaftsforschung
auch das sind zeichen wo man sieht wie
die innovation durch bundes durch
haushaltsmitteln unterstützt werden und
deshalb ist das ein gutes haushalt dem
man zustimmen kann er fördert die wende
zur sozial ökologischen wirtschaft und
deshalb seit 1863 spd schafft soziale
verantwortung vielen da
sagt der wirtschaftspolitische sprecher
der spd-bundestagsfraktion
bernd westphal in dieser debatte über
den etat des
bundeswirtschaftsministers wer hat
alexander ullrich ist der nächste redner
kommt aus der linksfraktion ist sowohl
sprecher für europäische sozial und
wirtschaftspolitik als auch für
industriepolitik
beantwortet haben wir meinen sie denn
alles mit wir denn für viele menschen in
diesem land trifft das zwar zu bis zu 40
prozent der haushalte kommen nicht mehr
durch den monat viele schon vor des
krieges und corona aber für viele andere
stellen wir fest dass reichtum sich
anhäuft die zahl der millionäre
milliardäre steigt an die ölkonzerne
machen geschäfte ohne ende werden auch
von ihnen dabei unterstützt und das
zeigt wir haben in dieser krise die
soziale ungleichheit weiter aufeinander
es stimmt nicht dass wir alle ärmer
werden ein teil der gesellschaft wird
ärmer und da ist auch politisch von
ihnen gewollt
und wenn sie von wir reden dann können
sie auch nicht meinen rennen gern noch
heute die chance verpasst mal zu
erklären warum zum beispiel die
rentnerinnen der rentner an der
studierende die 300 euro energie geld
nicht bekommt aber sie als vizekanzler
bekommen die 300 euro finden sie dass
respektvoll wie es im wahlkampf und bei
der regierungsbildung gerissen hat nein
das respektlos kann sich das kabinett
bedient und nach un-angaben
und wenn wir hier auch darüber reden
vorredner war für soziale stadt 1847 für
sozialen austausch steht die spd der
ministerpräsident von niedersachsen hat
jetzt in einem bild am sonntag in der
jugend sagt er ist auch dafür dass bei
den rentnerinnen und rentner nachgelegt
wird leider wird man von der spd
bundestagsfraktion nicht ob sie das
unterstützt also an die bürgerinnen
bürger auch in niedersachsen der
ministerpräsident nach dem wahlkampf und
stieß mit dem wahltermin ist auch diese
aussage wieder fehl am platze sie machen
mal wieder etwas sie wollen die
rentnerinnen und rentner im stich lassen
dass die wahrheit und diese woche hat
das auch nochmals gezeigt
und herr bundesminister habe gestern hat
der kanzler angesprochen er will eine
konzertierte aktion zwischen
arbeitgebern und gewerkschaften wie man
dieser installation umgeht ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass sie als
wirtschaftsminister hier mal paar
hinweise geben wohin die konzertierte
aktion gehen soll sollen die leute
nochmals auf lohnerhöhungen verzichten
weil es der wirtschaft schwer geht soll
es einen ausgleich geben des staates wir
sagen klipp und klar mit den
gewerkschaften das was ich jetzt gemacht
haben ist halb klar wir brauchen
vielmehr in der entlastung von der
politik damit auch die menschen wirklich
auch da nicht im stich gelassen werden
in diesen krisen corona und ukraine
vielen dank
und es folgt die fdp fraktion mit ihrem
gegner rein erfunden
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
glaube olaf scholz hat gestern gesagt
zum friedrich merz der lager gegangen
ist er würde durch die rede tänzeln herr
spahn
sie haben auch ziemlich viel getänzelt
also wenn die große kompetenz der union
darin besteht und sie jetzt zu empfehlen
wieder in die atomwirtschaft
einzusteigen muss ich sagen wo haben sie
eigentlich ihren marktwirtschaftlichen
bombers sie wissen doch ganz genau dass
keine bank ein atomkraftwerk in
deutschland finanzieren wird und sie
wissen ganz genau dass keine
versicherung ein atomkraftwerk
versichert würde und in dem zusammenhang
kann ich nur sagen ich empfehle dann die
endlagersuche in münsterland erspart
[Applaus]
die aussage zum gasspeicher dann gucken
sie doch bitte in die täglichen
informationen der bundesnetzagentur wie
das einspeichern in unsere da speicher
funktioniert und in welchem tempo sie
stattfinden dann könnten sie solche
aussagen die sie hier getroffen haben
eigentlich nicht voranbringen also das
kann meiner meinung nach nichts sagen
natürlich müssen wir der deutschen
wirtschaft danken sie akzeptiert das
primat der politik aber meine damen und
herren die wirtschaft ist natürlich auch
in großer sorge
und deswegen begrüßen wir als fdp
natürlich die verstärkten anstrengungen
gerade bei lng und herr minister es ist
natürlich traurig dass sie verkünden
haben also liebe ich will jetzt nicht
unbedingt sagen vorfeld organisiert zu
den grünen aber
bnd und nabu und so weiter und so fort
bitte klagt nicht gegen den bau dieser
energie anlagen dieser nötigen
infrastruktur in den helfen damit lng
eingespeichert werden kann nun findet
das leider trotzdem statt vielleicht
haben sie an der stelle ja auch noch ein
bisschen einfluss
und meine damen und herren ich
finde es ist schon starker tobak erfuhr
ich dass sie dieser bundesregierung
vorwerfen wir würden
armut sozusagen zu unserem politischen
konzept erhoben haben das ist blanker
populismus
das ist ein
das ist ein niveau was manchmal noch
nicht mal von dieser fraktion auf dieser
seite des hauses geboten wird und ich
muss sie wirklich fragen ob sie meinen
ihre partei wieder erfolgreich ins
politische geschäft bringen zu wollen
wenn sie mit solchen populistischen
argumenten hier rumhantiert vielen dank
reinhard houben war das der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion im bundestag in der debatte
über den etat des ministeriums für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz jetzt
hansjörg durz obmann im
wirtschaftsausschuss und er gehört der
csu landesgruppe an
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
gerade in dieser haushaltswoche in der
sich diese bundesregierung
brutto fast
10.000 neue stellen genehmigt ist schon
nochmal darauf hinzuweisen dass alles
was ausgegeben wird vorher
erwirtschaftet werden muss
einen einen großen beitrag zu unserer
wirtschaft direkt in den vergangenen
jahren der export unsere
exportorientierte wirtschaft hat in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten stark von der
globalisierung
profitiert doch oft schätzt man ja etwas
erst dann wenn man es nicht mehr hat
oder nicht man mich wer in der form hat
wie man es gewohnt ist wie eine welt
ohne funktionierende lieferketten ohne
freien zugang zu märkten mit weniger
oder ohne globalisierung
aussieht oder aussehen könnte das
erfahren wir gerade in dieser zeit der
hunger auf der welt wächst energie wird
knapp und die preise steigen rapide die
inflation betrug bei uns in deutschland
im vergangenen monat knapp acht prozent
in europa sogar über acht prozent und
spätestens jetzt das dürfte jedem klar
geworden sein freie hand wohlstand
die
in dieser zeit viel zitierte seitenwände
erfordert von uns allen neues denken und
neues handeln ich freue mich deshalb
dass sich ausgerechnet ein grüner
minister in davos zum freien welthandel
bekannt sind aber
klare worte in davos
noch wichtiger wäre entschiedenes
handeln in berlin
die die grünen blockieren allerdings
nach wie vor in jeder sitzungswoche in
der wir den antrag stellen das
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada ja mit
kanada es gibt außerhalb europas wohl
kein land das europäische ist wie kanada
haha wegverhandelt zwar mit qatar was ja
richtig ist um unsere energieversorgung
zu sichern
doch was ist das für ein widerspruch ein
deutscher wirtschaftsminister verbeugt
sich vor der katarischen scheichs doch
mit kanadischen demokraten schafft er
bis heute keinen handschlag habe ich
bitte sie überzeugen sie ihre partei und
stimmen sie dem freihandelsabkommen mit
kanada schnellstmöglich zu
in dieser woche findet wir haben es
bereits
gehört in hannover die größte
industriemesse der welt statt die
hannover messe geht heute zu ende
auch dort sind die auswirkungen der
aktuellen globalen entwicklungen
sichtbar und spürbar die messe findet
nur mit etwa der hälfte der aussteller
im vergleich zur vorgänger zeit statt
vor allem weil chinesen und inder nicht
oder kaum präsent sind doch diese messe
zeigt auch auf wie erfolgreiche
wirtschaftspolitik gelingen kann und
auch gelingt denn wer sie besucht der
erlebt dort trotz all der krisen in
dieser branche sie den anderen burschen
in unserem land anders aus aber dieser
branche
innovationskraft und zuversicht
und derjenige der dort ist kann erfahren
wo deutschland vorne liegt an der spitze
liegt zb bei der digitalen vernetzung
von fabriken und anlagen bei industrie
4.0 und ein grund dafür ist die
zusammenarbeit von staat und wirtschaft
im rahmen der plattform industrie 4.0
eingesetzt von einer unionsgeführten
bundesregierung sie hat bewiesen kluge
und zielgerichtete unterstützung
innovationsförderung und zusammenarbeit
stärkt die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen wirtschaft und genau das
brauchen wir jetzt auch
unsere anträge die das untermauert
kantaten und schluss der kulturen
abgelehnt ihr wollt vor präsident was
fast zu erwarten war aber wie beamte den
wohlstand von morgen
erwirtschaftet man nicht mit fast 10.000
neue stellen sondern mit einer politik
die nicht nur geld umverteilt sondern
wachstum und wohlstand möglich macht
vielen dank
hansjörg durz aus der unionsfraktion und
hier geht es weiter mit einer trainerin
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
nämlich der opfer im
wirtschaftsausschuss mehlis segnen
die hier ihre erste rede hält übrigens
im bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren für die
transformation brauchen wir einen wachen
gründergeist kreative ideen und kluge
köpfe
das war das rezept für die erfindungen
angefangen vom fahrrad und im
automobilen bis hin zum lanz traktor die
den menschen in der landwirtschaft die
arbeit erleichtert hat als gebürtige
mannheimerin bin ich natürlich stolz
darauf dass diese erfindungen aus meiner
heimatstadt kommen
und genauso und genau so muss es in
unserem land weitergehen denn was wir
jetzt brauchen sind zündende ideen und
innovationskraft die startups die
gründerinnen und gründer von heute sind
der mittelstand von morgen deswegen
müssen wir junge menschen für das
unternehmertum begeistern ob jemand in
unserem land gründen kann darf eben
nicht davon abhängig sein wie dick der
eigene geldbeutel ist
wir können und dürfen es uns nicht mehr
leisten auf talente zu verzichten weil
sie das nötige startkapital ich
mitbringen oder kein studium absolvieren
konnten an universitäten und hochschulen
gelingt uns das bereits second zum
beispiel mit dem ausbildungsprogramm ex
ist was wir aufgestockt haben das muss
aber auch an berufsschulen möglich sein
damit wir die gründungs landschaft in
unserem land zum beispiel mit
handwerksberufen diverser und breite
aufstellen können
investitionen in innovation sind teuer
sie sind aber unbedingt notwendig wenn
wir als wirtschaftsstandort
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben wollen für
kleine und mittelständische unternehmen
immer wieder eine große herausforderung
denn sie haben eben nicht die budgets
und noch nicht die kapazitäten der
großen konzerne deswegen haben wir uns
in mpeg gemeinsam dafür stark gemacht
dass innovationsprogramm für den
mittelstand um 80 millionen euro
aufzustocken
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
kann mich noch gut daran erinnern wie
ich als kleines mädchen mein vater nach
seiner frühschicht am benz werk abgeholt
habe ich weiß was die transformation für
ihn und seine kollegen bedeutet
ich weiß auch dass wir ohne deren know
how und ohne gut ausgebildete fachkräfte
die bevorstehenden aufgaben nicht
meistern können deswegen müssen wir
gemeinsam mit hochschulen und anderen
bildungsträgern menschen in den
betrieben weiter qualifizieren mit
regionalen und tagsüber kann weiterhin
gemeinsam mit ausbildungs und mit dem
längst überfälligen
bürokratieabbau bei der anerkennung von
ausländischen qualifikationen so können
wir unternehmen
[Applaus]
gewinnen
all diese punkte werden im haushalt
abgebildet denn wir stehen für einen
umbruch bei dem wir die menschen
mitnehmen damit dieser umbruch zum
echten aufbruch wird pina
dem dank
für die afg abzug folgt steffen patrick
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren also wir stehen dicht vor allem
umbruch wir stehen vor einem
zusammenbruch in der wirtschafts- und
energiepolitik und dieser haushalt der
bedeutet leider ein weiter so in die
energie- und wirtschafts und
gesellschaftskrise hinein dieser
haushalt strotzt wieder nur so vor
propagandistischen geologischen
dummheiten als könnte deutschland als
einziges land den klimawandel irgendwie
aufhalten
und was bedeutet die propaganda formel
des sogenannten klimaschutzes der
klimaschutz in links grüner lesart wird
auch bald offiziell für eine
zweistellige links-grün getriebene
inflation stehen der sogenannte
klimaschutz steht für die höchsten
strompreise er steht für eine
beschleunigte
deindustrialisierung und das brechen von
versorgungsketten der sogenannte
klimaschutz steht für
umweltverschmutzung zerstörung von
grundwasser system wäldern und der
lebensgrundlage von meerestieren der
sogenannte klimaschutz mal am tag steht
für die größte um verteilung der
steuergelder hin zu den hoch
subventionierten
konzernen der grünen energiewende ins
nichts meine damen und herren und
letztlich bedeutet diese politik die
abwesenheit von vernunft fachwissen
wissenschaft ehrlichkeit und wahrheit
wer es denn ehrlich meinen würde der
würde unsere gesellschaft
widerstandsfähig machen gegen den
klimawandel
also hochwasserschutz
wassermanagement widerstandsfähige
pflanzen wo bleiben denn die investition
in kernfusion in den weiterbetrieb der
kern energie hier fehlanzeige
weil in diesem haushalt der gesunde
menschenverstand
fehlt und an dieser stelle und an dieser
stelle ersparen das stimmt ja wie hohen
sie ihre partei und frau merkel waren
doch gerade
anlass punkte und diejenigen die den
ausstieg aus der kernenergie forciert
haben und wenn sie das jetzt hier
fordern dann ist das eigentlich nichts
anderes als ruhe meine damen und herren
aber wohin uns die links grüne politik
führen wird das können wir hier und da
und mal dort aufblitzen sehen das
gasnetz
deutschlands soll zerstört werden das
hat nicht nur einfach wissen befreiter
staatssekretär patrick reichen verlauten
lassen nein das ist leider auch die
position des wirtschaftsministeriums
zitat aus dem ministerium für das ende
ihrer nutzung gemeint sind die gasnetze
sollten die betroffenen netzbetreiber
rechtzeitig vorsorge treffen wir haben
500 1000 kilometer an gasverteilnetzen
für 1,6 millionen industrie und
gewerbekunden 19 millionen haushalte
liegen da dran sie versorgen uns die
gasnetze mit sicherer wärme und energie
und das gras netz würden wir nicht
brauchen sagen nun die grünen muss
jünger scheint sich hingegen bei den
grünen durchgesetzt zu haben
das gasnetz abreißen zu wollen ja das
ist nichts anderes als marius großer
sprung nach vorn in orange der
physikalischen gesetzmäßigkeiten und als
getan zum schluss ergeht ische verarmung
der bürger und ein gänzlich und
vernünftiger weise könnte man die
nutzung der netze einstellen nein sie
sollen aber abmontiert werden und
tatsachen geschaffen werden und das ist
eine taktik der verbrannten erde die mit
uns nicht geht und kollegen als und
letzter satz und ich als ehemaliges
mitglied der fdp appelliere auch an sie
dieses mittel der bundesregierung
beenden sie diesen irrsinn und kehren
wir sagen muss dass viele versicherte
energieversorgung vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hält das wort
andreas mail treffer
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin damen und
herren wenn wir wegen dem sondervermögen
bundeswehr beim klimaschutz sparen
müssen nein diese sorge der wir immer
wieder begegnen in diesen tagen ist
unbegründet mit dem haushalt 2022 und
insbesondere mit dem klima und
transformation hsv- stellen wir die
mittel zur verfügung die wir brauchen um
unsere klimaziele zu erreichen über den
klima und transformationsphase
investieren wir in diesem jahr rund 28
milliarden euro in unsere energie und
klimapolitik und bis 2026 werden das gut
200 milliarden sein das sind 200
milliarden euro für den klimaschutz für
mehr erneuerbare energien für gedämmte
gebäude für den aufbau von wasserstoff
technologie und für die förderung der
elektromobilität
das sind gut angelegte 200 milliarden
euro mit denen wir für eine gute zukunft
vor baumann damen und herren
ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
denen passt das ja anscheinend nicht sie
klagen gerade gegen 60 dieser 200
milliarden sie klagen damit gegen mehr
klimaschutz gegen grünen strom und gegen
die zukunftsfähigkeit unserer wirtschaft
und nicht nur das sie klagen auch gegen
die unabhängigkeit von fossilen
energieträgern und gegen die
unabhängigkeit von russland ja auch
darum geht es erneuerbare energien sind
der einzige weg für eine sichere saubere
und bezahlbare stromversorgung dagegen
zu klagen dass ich schon eine besonders
irrwitzige idee
meine damen und herren wir müssen die
treibhausgasemissionen
rasch und tiefgreifend reduzieren das
steht außer frage wir müssen unsere
klimaziele in allen sektoren erreichen
auch das steht außer frage und wir
wollen das so umsetzen dass wir
niemanden damit überfordern mit dem
bundeshaushalt und dem klima und
transformations- vortragen wird dem
rechnung wir finanzieren den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jetzt aus dem
bundeshaushalt stadt über die
stromrechnung für die energieeffizienz
von gebäuden stellen wir rund acht
milliarden euro zur verfügung wir
fördern den umstieg auf e mobilität mit
fünf milliarden euro mit xto global
sorgen wir für den markthochlauf von
grünem wasserstoff für die nationale
klimaschutzinitiative
konnten wir die mittel noch einmal um
220 millionen euro aufstocken und mit
1,2 milliarden euro für 2022 und
insgesamt rund 24 milliarden für die
nächsten jahre ermöglichen wir
klimaschutz verträge mit denen die
industrie ihre produktion auf
erneuerbare energien umstellen kann
mit diesem bundeshaushalt können wir
unser energiesystem schnellstmöglich
klimafreundlich umbauen wir können
endlich bei der sanierung unserer
gebäude von ankommen und wir machen die
energiewende zu einer sozialen in die
wende all das packen wir jetzt mit dem
haushalt an
wichtigen gesetze zur umsetzung sind
bereits auf dem weg mit dem neuen
erneuerbare energien gesetz werden wir
den ausbau der erneuerbaren massiv
beschleunigen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union in
pressemitteilung vom sonntag zur
hannover messe schreiben sie viel vom
bürokratieabbau teams jetzt bräuchte wir
kämen auf jeden fall beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren noch schneller weiter wenn
cdu und csu hier beim bürokratieabbau
vorangehen würden sollten sie jedoch
dafür dass blockierende regelungen wie
die 10h regel in bayern aufgehoben
werden das wäre mal ein sinnvoller
beitrag verdienen
bestellen die förderung beim gebiet
gebäudebereich auf neue füße damit wir
auch dort in zukunft endlich unsere
klimaziele erreichen zu viel co2 im
gebäudesektor heißt auch viele
mieterinnen und mieter zahlen zu viel
fürs heizen es ist deswegen notwendig
dass wir die co2 steuer auf öl und gas
fair zwischen vermietern und mietern
auch verteilen
wir brauchen anreize für vermieterinnen
und vermieter gebäude energetisch zu
sanieren es liegt ja nicht nur am
individuellen eigenverbrauch der metro
mieter wie teuer das heiz ist es liegt
eben auch daran wie gut die wohnung die
damned ist und wie alt die heizung ist
mit den beiden entlastungs paketen haben
wir bereits wichtige grundlagen für eine
soziale energiewende gelegt über 30
milliarden euro haben wir bisher frei
gemacht um bürgerinnen und bürger von
steigenden lebenshaltungskosten
zu entlasten die absenkung der eeg
umlage auf null ist eine der wichtigsten
maßnahmen dabei mit der wir sozial
gerecht entlasten und gleichzeitig auch
den umstieg auf
erneuerbare herstellbaren strom fördern
diesen weg müssen wir konsequent
weitergehen wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag ein klima geld
angeführt dicht vereinbart ist ein
sozialer ausgleich für die co2 preise
über eine absenkung der eeg umlage
hinaus ein vorschlag liegt er jetzt auf
dem tisch
beim klima geld geht es aber nicht nur
um kurzfristige entlastungen das
geplante weitere anstieg ansteigenden
der co2 preise muss sich auch in einem
steigenden klima geld widerspiegeln das
sozial gerecht diejenigen belohnt die
wenig co2 verbrauchen
meine damen und herren klimaschutz steht
bei uns auch in krisenzeiten oben auf
datei soll der haushalt und insbesondere
die mittel für den klima- und
transformation zu zeigen das deutlich
wir finanzieren eine soziale
energiewende wir finanzieren eine
sichere saubere und bezahlbare
energieversorgung
das ist das signal dieses haushalts und
das ist dass richtiges meer
der bundestag debattiert über den
einzelplan oder im neuen wirtschaft und
klimaschutz und der nächste winter kommt
von der fdp der klimapolitische sprecher
seiner fraktion
olaf in der beek
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen lieber kollege
kathrin lieber kollege kommen
ich glaube glauben sie mir wirklich die
freien demokraten können sie sehr
glücklich schätzen dass mitglieder wie
sie nicht nur in unseren reihen sind und
glauben sie mir auch 1 wir werden sie
auch nicht mehr aufnehmen
im einzelplan nun neun
um zum thema zu kommen im einzelplan 09
ist unser gemeinsamer anspruch die
bereiche wirtschaft klimaschutz energie
auch haushaltspolitisch miteinander in
einklang zu bringen dass es für uns als
stark industrienationen herausforderung
und anspruch zugleich unser anspruch ist
für die menschen und unternehmen in
unserem land die besten
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen wir müssen
ambitionierte ziele verfolgen und
unnötige belastung verhindern wir wollen
dass deutschland wirtschaftlich stark
bleibt und klimapolitisch erfolgreich
ist wir investieren unter anderem in
industrie forschung in energieforschung
und konkrete maßnahmen zum schutz von
klima und biodiversität
dabei handelt es sich nicht nur um
maßnahmen zur förderung und stärkung der
entwicklung unserer wirtschaft wir
schützen damit auch unser klima wir
wollen wir wollen diesen weg gemeinsam
mit unserer wirtschaft und dabei
besonders mit dem mittelstand und dem
handwerk gehen die unternehmen in
deutschland sind partner beim erreichen
unserer ziele sie sind nicht teil des
problems sondern teil der lösung nur
gemeinsam
nur gemeinsam liebe kolleginnen kollegen
können wir wirtschaft und gesellschaft
das klima schützen politikern hier nur
für gute rahmenbedingungen sorgen wir
müssen auch in finanzieller hinsicht
zügig unsere hausaufgaben machen mit dem
aktuellen haushalt haben wir damit
begonnen die wirtschaft braucht zum
erreichen der klimaziele langfristige
planungssicherheit aber geld allein ist
nicht alles viel hilft viel darf nicht
der grundsatz unserer
haushaltspolitischen agenda seien auch
beim klimaschutz muss sichergestellt
werden dass steuerfinanzierte maßnahmen
einen entsprechenden nutzen haben eine
ständige überprüfung der investitionen
ist deshalb unerlässlich
der aufwuchs der mittel im
bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz ist richtig bringt aber
ebenso die pflicht zur sorgfalt und
achtsamkeit mit sich
wichtig und das möchte ich auch noch mal
bezogen wichtig ist auch die
nachhaltigkeit unserer haushaltspolitik
mit der schnellen rückkehr zur
schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr denn
kommende generation schon bin nicht nur
effizienten klimaschutz sondern auch
solide staatsfinanzen
selbstverständlich beschleunigen wir
weiter die energiewende denn die
umstellung von fossilen zu erneuerbaren
energien wird nämlich mittelfristig die
energie preise senken dafür brauchen wir
eine offensive auch für bürokratieabbau
und planungs beschleunigung so werden
auch private investitionen in
klimaschutz deutlich attraktiver mit
diesem haushalt legen wir den grundstein
für die entwicklung unseres landes in zu
einem starken und klimafreundlichen
industriestandort vielen dank
und für die cdu csu fraktion spricht
jetzt dr andreas lenz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
herausforderungen sind groß keine frage
der krieg in der ukraine die
auswirkungen auf die fragen der
versorgungssicherheit aber auch
natürlich die frage der inflation im
land die die ärmsten natürlich am
stärksten trifft und wir sind
konstruktiv wenn es darum geht lösungen
für diese herausforderungen zu finden
das haben wir auch die zeit bei meventi
gesetzt aber auch bei merzig und bei
vielen mehr wir sind aber auch kritisch
wenn es um ihre maßnahmen und um den
vorgelegten haushalt entsprechend geht
es hat nichts mit den grundsätzen von
wahrheit und klarheit zu tun wenn sie
ein recht wie an den rechtlich
fragwürdigen transformation store in
höhe von 60 milliarden euro vor sich her
schieben das sagt übrigens auch zu recht
der bundesrechnungshof und es ist ja
irgendwie so wie bei einem eichhörnchen
dass sich einen die hamsterten fordert
anliegt und diesen dann nicht mehr
findet wir könnten schon jetzt die
nettoneuverschuldung signifikant senken
wenn entsprechend die rücklagen
aufgelöst werden und es ist doch so dass
ihr transformations- von nicht
umgestaltet er gestaltet nicht um das
geld liegt doch einfach nur herum und
darum geht's weiter und wenn ich gerade
schon bei ihnen bin herr meter es ist
wirklich in form uns vorzuwerfen dass
wir beim ausbau der erneuerbaren bremsen
zu schaffen doch gerade die wasserkraft
in bayern und deutschland ab und das ist
doch der punkt
und überhaupt und überhaupt und
überhaupt weiß man nicht so recht wie
die ampel im moment gerade ampel
schaltet auf welche farbe es ist es ist
doch so es ist doch so dass der co2
zertifikaten handelt der fdp den sie ja
in der letzten legislatur immer vor sich
hergetragen haben überhaupt nicht
stattfindet im gegenteil dazu schlägt
die spd ein klima geld vor dass
anscheinend mit die wiederum nicht
abgestimmt ist also was wollen sie denn
jetzt die ampel hampelt herum und um
eines klar zu sagen das ist kein das ist
kein das ist kein klarer kurs sehr
geehrte damen und herren
wichtig wichtig bleibt die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft und da gibt es nach wie vor
viel zu tun sprechen sie doch mal mit
den unternehmerinnen mit den unternehmen
die rückmeldungen sind hier mehr als
alarmierend und die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage das muss man ja auch ganz
klar sagen kostet dem haushalt keinen
euro kaufen weitere entlassungen gerade
was die stromsteuer aber auch dass
maßnahmen darüber hinaus besitzt und
eine sehr gute ich ihnen auch noch sagen
ich schätze hier sehr aber sie
setzen die begrenzte
laufzeitverlängerung gleich mit dem bau
neuer atomkraftwerke das will natürlich
niemand und das ist auch ein
signifikanter unterschied
und da können sie auch gerne mal mit
ihren kollegen sprechen die entsprechend
auch sich unseren forderungen bereits
angeschlossen haben
es ist so ist es so dass natürlich es
ungerecht ist dass die energiepreise
pauschale 300 euro die renterinnen und
rentner nicht bekommen die studierenden
nicht bekommen wir fordern außerdem höre
heizkostenzuschüsse und eine erhöhung
der pendlerpauschale ab dem ersten
kilometer
und es ist doch klar bei einer
signifikanten installation muss man
entsprechend entlasten es kann doch
nicht sein dass der staat zum inflations
gewinner zum krisengewinnler wird ja
noch einen punkt der betrifft die
bundesförderung effizienter managen und
da würde ich mich gerne an sie wenden
bundesminister habeck wir brauchen hier
investitionssicherheit für die kommunen
die kommunen sind startklar um bei den
fähren und bei den nahwärmenetzen zu
investieren für mehr klimaschutz gehen
sie noch mal nach brüssel und schauen
sie dass das programm entsprechend auch
abgerufen werden kann wir brauchen auch
einen hochlauf der wasserstoffwirtschaft
wir dürfen keine zeit verlieren wir
brauchen einen ausbau der infra struktur
keinen abbau der infrastruktur
gebrauchen auch
wettbewerbsfähigen stahl zukünftig co2
made in germany und noch ein letzter
satz das von ihnen angerichtete kfw
fördert desaster scheint wirklich zum
himmel die anhörungen und auch die
anhörung gerade auch in dieser woche
haben ihnen ein verheerendes urteil
ausgestellt die zahl von 400.000 neuen
wohnungen wird nicht erreicht werden sie
werden ihr ziel krachen verfehlen gegen
sie auch hier planungssicherheit seien
sie kreativ wenn es darum geht die
wohnungsnot zu lindern kommen sie mit
eigenen heimes zu fördern herzlichen
dank
der nächste redner in der debatte kommt
von den bündnisgrünen
stefan schmidt er ist der sprecher für
tourismus die seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen zum
jahr gegen ende dieser debatte möchte
ich den fokus auf eine ganz besondere
branche richten eine branche die von der
pandemie so stark gebeutelt war und ist
wie kaum eine andere nämlich die
tourismusbranche über die schmerzhaften
coro langzeitfolgen haben wir ja erst am
montag auf dem tourismus gipfel
gesprochen deshalb ist es gut und
wichtig dass wir gemeinsam mit den ampel
fraktionen hier die haushaltsmittel für
den tourismus noch mal deutlich
aufstocken konnten wir nehmen sechs
millionen euro wir nehmen sechs
millionen euro zusätzlich in die hand
und kurbeln den tourismus an zum einen
starten wir die dzt die deutsche
zentrale für tourismus mit mehr als 39
millionen euro aus die die cd ist unser
aushängeschild im ausland nach den
harten corona jahren und während eines
brutalen angriffs kriegs in europa ist
es wichtig dass wir der dcc ordentlich
geld in die hand geben damit sie im
ausland werden kann für deutschland als
zukunftsorientiertes als friedvolles als
sicheres reiseland zum anderen
investieren wir mit knapp drei millionen
nur soviel geld wie nie zuvor in die
sogenannte leistungssteigerungen also in
die innovationen im tourismusgewerbe vor
allem bei der digitalisierung auch beim
umwelt und klimaschutz hat die branche
noch luft nach oben und mit den
haushaltsmitteln unterstützen wir sie
und machen so gemeinsam mit den ländern
den tourismusstandort deutschland
zukunftsfähig
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
ich freue mich sehr über den tourismus
sieht damit investieren wir nicht nur in
den tourismus wir würdigen ihn auch denn
eine branche die mehr zur
bruttowertschöpfung beiträgt als der
maschinenbau und die mehr menschen
arbeit gibt als die automobilindustrie
diese branche müssen wir finanziell und
politisch entsprechend wertschätzen das
tun wir mit diesem haushalt das tun wir
mit vielen anderen projekten die wir als
koalition vorgesehen haben und die wir
in stetigen austausch mit der branche
und mit der gesellschaft entwickeln
vielen dank
für die spd-fraktion spricht lena werner
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte bürger in liebe kollegin zuerst
einmal möchte ich mich ganz herzlich bei
all denjenigen bedanken die unabhängig
aller herausforderungen der letzten
beiden jahre weiter im tourismus
arbeiten und die menschen bekommen heißt
es möglich machen zu reisen und die das
nach außen tragen dass diese branche
ausmacht herzlichkeit gastfreundlichkeit
und fröhlichkeit
mein dank gilt dabei aber nicht nur
denjenigen die man vielleicht sofort
denkt die die servicekräfte kräfte in
der gastro die rezeptionistin im hotel
oder die mitarbeiter in den reisebüros
ich danke auf dem busfahrer innen und
bahnfahrer in den reiseveranstalter in
den konzerten konzertveranstalter in den
techniker in den campingplatz betreiber
in den jugend reiseanbieter in den
freizeitpark den netzbetreiber in den
lebensmittelerzeuger in und noch viel
mehr
die merken schon zum terrorismus gehört
eine vielzahl verschiedener bereiche mit
vielen millionen mitarbeitende aber was
leistet der tourismus eigentlich
tourismus trägt positiv zur
infrastrukturellen entwicklung von
regionen bei tourismus schafft
arbeitsplätze und unterstützt somit
wirtschaftlicher unabhängigkeit vor
allem auch in strukturschwachen regionen
und den ländern des globalen südens
tourismus lässt bildungsarbeit tourismus
bringt menschen zusammen und macht
kulturen für alle zugänglich tourismus
ist ein brückenbauer und eine
wirtschaftskraft
gerade in der aktuellen weltlage ist es
wichtig dass ein internationaler
austausch und eine völkerverständigung
stattfinden dazu trägt der tourismus bei
im jahr 2019 vor pandemie und krieg lag
die wertschöpfung des innerdeutschen
tourismus bei
123,8 milliarden euro das entspricht
3,99 prozent der bruttowertschöpfung in
deutschland und mein kollege stephan
schmidt gerade schon angesprochen damit
liegt der tourismus in der wertschöpfung
sogar über dem maschinenbau der bei 35
prozent lag
die wirtschaftlichen einbrüche der
korona pandemie in der branche waren
enorm
wir brauchen deshalb jetzt einen
nachhaltigen neustart und diesen werden
wir mit der nationalen
tourismusstrategie gewährleisten
der fokus der strategie doch unter
anderem auf der bekämpfung des
fachkräftemangels sowie der schaffung
von sozialer und ökonomischer
nachhaltigkeit
um dies zu erreichen umsetzen zu können
bitten wir alle aktuellen in die
prozesse ein und die zahlen sprechen für
sich ich bin sehr froh dass die
bundesregierung die bedeutung des
tourismus für deutschland als
wirtschaftskraft erkannt hat und genau
das zeigt der haushaltsplan zu dem ich
hier heute sprechen darf
insgesamt sieht der haushaltsplan 42
millionen euro für den tourismus vor und
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich einmal
bei unserem zuständigen haushälter frank
junge bedanken der sich stark für diese
gelder eingesetzt hat
die deutsche zentrale für tourismus
erhält für ihre sehr wichtige arbeit die
werbung für das reiseland deutschland
39 millionen euro das sind 4,5 millionen
euro mehr als im ersten entwurf
vorgesehen dazu kommen weitere drei
millionen euro zur förderung der
leistungssteigerung im tourismusgewerbe
mit diesen mitteln werden nicht nur die
in deutschland einzigartigen
reichhaltigen natur und
kulturlandschaften sondern vor allem
auch naturnahe urlaubsform oder auch der
städtetourismus gefördert so wird zum
beispiel auch meine heimatregion um
eifel mosel gezielt gefördert denn
gerade der ländliche raum hat einen
großen anteil am tourismus in
deutschland
der tourismussektor ist insbesondere im
globalen süden aber auch bei uns
anfällig für die folgen des klimawandels
das haben wir im letzten jahr durch das
hochwasser im aartal und in der eifel
deutlich zu spüren bekommen
daher ist es von großer bedeutung dass
förderprogramme wie das lif projekt und
das kompetenzzentrum
tourismus des bundes weitere
fördermittel erhalten
im fokus stehen wird den neuen programm
nicht wissen projekte zu nachhaltigkeit
und digitalisierung im tourismus
nachhaltigkeit ist insbesondere in der
tourismuspolitik ein enorm wichtiger
faktor sei es umweltschutz der erhalt
der biodiversität oder das
einsparpotenzial von co2 luft und
schiffsverkehr
wir dürfen hier nicht nachlässig sein
um kurze folgt wie zu zitieren die
größte sehenswürdigkeit die es gibt ist
die welt und deswegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren mein appell an
sie gehen sie wieder auf konzerte auf
reisen gehen sie essen entdecken sie die
neue städte landschaften und kulturen
sei es in deutschland europa oder der
welt
die nächste rednerin kommt von der
cdu/csu und dürfte jedem bekannt sein
anja karliczek die ehemalige
bundesbildungsministerin ist jetzt
tourismuspolitische sprecherin der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
nach wie vor den eindruck nicht los
werden dass die sorgen und nöte der
tourismusindustrie die echten sorgen in
der ampel nicht richtig angekommen sind
und dass sie auch nicht in der lage sind
das wirklich im blick zu weiten es kann
doch nicht so schwer sein in diesen
zeiten geeignete und notwendige
maßnahmen zur unterstützung der menschen
und der unternehmen im tourismus zu
identifizieren ich will ihnen mal
ich will ihnen drei beispiele nennen wir
haben gerade über die deutsche zentrale
für tourismus schon gehört dass es einen
aufwuchs von sechs millionen gegeben hat
im verhältnis zu 20 21 sind 34 millionen
weniger aber letztes jahr haben die zehn
millionen hat zu gekriegt und in diesem
jahr sind die wieder gekürzt worden um 6
millionen wieder drauf zu legen also für
mich macht das nach adam riese man 2 4
millionen weniger
und das zweite sie stellen das immer so
als großtat da ich will das mal im
verhältnis stehen zu dem was unsere
nachbarländer machen deutschland
investiert 47 cent pro kopf in die
werbung in die außenwerbung in die dzt
österreich 3 eur 10 und unsere
schweizerischen nachbarn sogar fünf
franken 96 nur mal um lasst uns
verhältnis zu setzen wie wichtig die
tourismusindustrie in diesem land und
wie wenig wir das hier im haben das was
da passieren muss wir müssen uns aber
eines klar sein für amerika und für
chinesen ist krieg in europa und wir
müssen doch deswegen eins tun jetzt
überall auf der welt klar zu machen dass
sind mitteleuropa attraktives reisen
noch möglich ist und lieber ampel ich
glaube da ist noch luft nach oben
ein zweites beispiel will ich ihnen
nennen das gar nicht drüber gesprochen
worden bis jetzt sie lehnen die
dauerhafte senkung der mehrwertsteuer
auf gastronomische speisen ab 7 prozent
auf speisen in restaurants kneipen und
cafés sie können sich nicht dazu
durchringen ihre antwort auf unseren
antrag in der letzten sitzungswoche
verschieben unseres antrags in den
ausschuss was bedeutet das mal sehen
vielleicht irgendwann liebe haben wir
was sind denn versprechen ihres
bundeskanzlers und ihres finanzministers
in diesen tagen eigentlich noch wert
konsequenzen ihrer zögerlichen haltung
ihrer untätigkeit ist doch hoffen
verunsicherung auf einer seite vergessen
und bei gastronomen und wenn sie den
omas und opas in diesem land schon
keinen inflationsausgleich zukommen
lassen dann sollten sie ihn wenigstens
die möglich geben möglichkeit geben
frühzeitig zu wissen ob sie sich das
schnitzel mit der familie am sonntag im
restaurant noch leisten können und ich
will noch einen anderen punkt stark
machen an der stelle wenn die gäste
ausbleiben dann stirbt auch ein stück
lebenskultur für die menschen vor ort es
gibt den schönen satz wenn die letzte
kneipe im dorf stirbt stirbt das dorf so
sagt man es bei uns und das ist kein
spruch sondern den ländlichen regionen
bittere wahrheit und kurz und knapp noch
ein letztes beispiel ich hatte letzte
woche erstmals seit zwei jahren wieder
besuch aus meinem wahlkreis
strahlende gesichter natürlich wegen des
spannenden politischen programms aber
natürlich auch weil endlich wieder
gemeinsam mit dem bus reisen möglich war
und dazu auch das busunternehmen die
trotz der hohen kraftstoffpreise
wettbewerbsfähig sind das 9 euro ticket
so sehr wie ich eben 29 euro ticket
gönne leistet für die busunternehmen
gerade einen bärendienst und wenn es am
ende keine busunternehmen ergibt da gibt
es eben auch keine busreisen mehr gucken
sie noch einmal drüber und helfen sie
denen die im moment wirklich in not sind
und
der letzte redner in der debatte des
einzelplan 10 09 wirtschaft und
klimaschutz kommt von der spd diese
weingarten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren eines der innovativsten felder
unserer volkswirtschaft ist die kultur
und kreativwirtschaft und auch sie hat
es verdient in dieser dem
wirtschaftspolitischen debatte erwähnt
und betrachtet zu werden
1,2 millionen menschen erwirtschaften
dort in rund 260.000 unternehmen einen
gesamtumsatz von mehr als 160 milliarden
euro es ist klare ziel unserer koalition
sie weiter nachhaltig zu unterstützen
denn die kultur und kreativwirtschaft
ist nicht nur wirtschaftlich von
bedeutung sie sind hier am kulturellen
bezug auf sinnstiftend hält die
gesellschaft zusammen und beantwortet
mit die frage wer wir sind und wer wir
sein wollen musik literatur film
rundfunk oder presse auch die
architektur stehen stellvertretend dafür
zugleich mussten wir in der pandemie
schmerzlich lernen dass diese
unternehmen anfällig sind für
rückschläge zwar waren die förderhilfen
sehr umfangreich für 325.000 anträge
wurden mehr als 4 milliarden euro
ausgezahlt aber nicht überall konnten
wir passgenau helfen hart getroffen
wurden vor allen dingen kunst und musik
und die filmwirtschaft hier wird die
koalition wege finden und beschäftigte
und unternehmen für künftige krisen
besser abzusichern
wir sind bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck neuer dankbar dass er im haushalt
2022 neue impulse setzt und zugleich
bewährtes wie beispiel die initiative
kultur und kreativwirtschaft der
bundesregierung
fortführt mit dem kompetenzzentrum
kultur und kreativwirtschaft können wir
potenziale für wirtschaft und
gesellschaft sichtbar machen
anlaufpunkte für zielgruppen schaffen
und insbesondere den klein- und
kleinstunternehmen
ansprechpartner geben das gilt
beispielsweise für unternehmen der
digitalen wirtschaft etwa im bereich der
computerspiele oder der industriellen
industrienahen simulationen sie können
nachhaltige lösungen entwickeln im
umweltbereich zum regionalen
strukturwandel oder zu teilhabe und
integration
insgesamt haben wir für solche
initiativen im einzelplan 09 rund 646
millionen euro vorgesehen das ist ein
klares bekenntnis zur förderung dieser
branchen
und wichtig ist in diesem zusammenhang
auch dass diese förderung eben nicht nur
aus mitteln des bundes
wirtschaftsministerium kommt auch der
bundes kulturetat steigt auf rund 2,3
milliarden euro etwa mit dem programm
neustart kultur oder der förderung von
musik literatur tanz und theater der
dank dieser koalition gilt deshalb auch
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth für
diese ressort übergreifende strategie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung die koalition stehen es
wird in den unternehmen und den
beschäftigten der kulturen
kreativwirtschaft wir unterstützen sie
materiell und konzeptionell denn sie
sind ein wichtiger teil unserer
wirtschaft und unserer gesellschaft
herzlichen dank
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
die fragen müssen sie später klären wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 09 bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz in der
ausschuss fassung wer stimmt dafür dass
ist spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
bestimmt dagegen dass es cdu csu fdp und
die linke enthaltung entsprechend keine
der einzelplan 09 ist angenommen